what's going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we are going to do a first
time watching for a movie I've been
clamoring to see for a very long time
and that is called Jennifer's Body I am
rejoined by the world girl herself Roxy
the straw Roxy how are you wow I got a
duh I like that only big people get
those the Australia Destroyer you're a
big person today huge
huge anyway Jennifer's Body you have not
seen this movie right no and honestly I
don't think I ever lie about having seen
movies but I think I've been lying about
having seen this movie for years because
it's just so not cool to have not seen
it uh people just kind of pester you if
you say you haven't seen this so people
will be like oh you've seen it I'm like
oh it's dope
sweet welcome to the not cool Club
ladies and Gentlemen please go ahead use
your body to maneuver your way to that
like button see how I did that also
you'd be a real fox if you can subscribe
and leave click that notification Bell
fumble the delivery there and and uh you
know
um patreon we got full length ratchet
and watch alongs re-sync up with your
own copy of Jennifer's Body we're
watching this off hippo Max today cover
several things exclusive over there with
reaction hats Watch Dogs included more
importantly if you want her to come back
you gotta follow her on the world girls
that's the only compromise we have made
today oh yeah we shook on it so this
will be awkward if you guys don't hook
it up and she needs at least five
followers and I think we can accomplish
that I'm counting slowly over my tears
one all right two
don't make me keep going four [__] roll
that intro
[Music]
Disney Disney's Jennifer's party
the family of classic I love how we
chose this movie today could have done a
much bigger movie but what would
Jennifer's Body
she's got like a hole in her arm what's
going on there like a burn Maybe
oh I hate that just chewing her hair oh
I hate that little kids do that
wow for only five seconds
pretty font it might be a rom-com Fall
Out Boy hello yeah I see you wanted to
touch it
not touching the show
what the hell
oh is this like hell is a teenage girl
remember in the future I guess I'm not
exactly perfect myself
but at least I have my fans that's how
Roxy says on Twitter that's Amanda
sacred speaking right now yeah I mean I
get letters every day
mostly from perverts and Chesters but
still this is my floor I'm kind of the
[__]
got it Queen
Rick time started five minutes ago needy
gracias rimondo I used to make these oh
so you really are her they tell me
everything will be okay if I just accept
Jesus Christ into my heart that's true
he was a Jew I say the words but nothing
ever happens
nobody comes back it's because you got
to believe I've been trying to convert
this one for ages
well those JV tactics won't work against
me her first name is needy I'm the
kicker I'm not sure Tolson could provide
sufficient energy during your day I
recommend more complex cobbler whoa
kicker indeed I recommend you shut the
[__] up
oh my God
oh damn kicker
oh I did not know what this movie was
it's a movie about mental health it used
to be normal well as normal as any girl
under the influence of teenage hormones
she does have Golem eyes but after the
killings began I started to feel loose
around the edges or something it's weird
that this is so known as Megan Fox's
movie and not Amanda seyfritz at all I
hate this song
this is where it all went down this does
have like an 80s movie Vibe it feels 90s
to me the place is just named after a
waterfall like Heathers and [__] like
that it goes into this hole and it
doesn't come out scientist guys dropped
all kinds of things down there but
nothing ever surfaces oh maybe it's
another dimension you could drop bodies
down there just two months ago me
Jennifer and my boyfriend Chip were
completely normal people
what do you think about devil as a
mascot I think it's satanic and
Antichrist people found it hard to
believe that a babe like Jennifer would
associate with a dork like me
I mean you're pretty attractive looking
dork yeah blue shoulder playing at
Melody Lane or this indie rock band from
the city I saw their Myspace page and
the lead singers extra salty
salty like not bitter but they get up at
8 30. wear something cute okay okay
damn she looks exactly the same today
interesting sounds like you're judging
her physical appearance no she's so hot
both places those jeans are hell low I
can almost see your front butt this boy
looks 12. I know this is my rock look
well I can see like your womb so
you don't know where her womb is honey
you guys go to Devil's Kettle high
school anyway the singer Guy Jennifer
says he's extra salty so salty salty
salty whatever salty means beautiful is
that what it means you must be soy sauce
babe oh good one
pick up line of the year that's why
you're the drummer we missed Valentine's
Day for that
we need to quit shampooing yourself and
get down here that's [__] weird
tamponing yourself
this real slang it's just that I like
the same things that she likes we have
stuff in common that's why we're biffs
oh oh hi chip
it smells like Thai food in here have
you guys been
oh my God
this is weird it's like a bingo hall
with Taps they're just Jello because
you're not invited Jello you're totally
Jello you're lime green Jello and you
can't even admit it to yourself yup
Jello [__] stop kidnapping my
girlfriend
your lime green Jello and you can't even
admit it something tells me Chip's gonna
die this movie you look really pretty he
thinks he's cute enough for me and
that's why he's in return that
aged well hey it's Ahmed from India I
wonder if he's circumcised I always want
to try sea cucumber
Jennifer check
poison yourself addiction is that
Christmas
we only do arrest you have a possession
you're not even out of the academy at
Roman
two more months
then I'm on the force for reals
you gonna cuff me oh don't do that
I can't get over this hey that's the
band
[Music]
I I had no idea Chris Pratt was in this
movie
okay Adam Brody Adams highlighter
they're wearing eyeliner yeah
you're a small time Gummer I wish we had
more guys like that until it's cuddle
small time what
I I don't know most of the dialogue I
was a teenage girl I don't know what
they're saying and I think around this
time this movie's made me an old man I
don't know what they're talking about
these are like smart bombs Point them in
the right direction and [__] gets real
okay really smart bombs huh shoulder
yeah we've heard I've heard about you
you player instrument s really
super good
why would you want to play all the way
out here in Devil's Kettle I think it's
really important sometimes to try and
connect with our fans in them
shitty there it is too
can I buy you a drink
sure what are we having
this Diet Pepsi red white and blue but
you have to drink it really fast or it
turns brownish all right we'll drink it
fast
you can't get alcohol though
oh honey I got to be 21. I'll just play
hello video with a bartender yeah oh
like I said I've been a teenage girl and
I'm a 45 year old man trying to
understand Jennifer's Body today how's
she gonna get the alcohol though her
smart bombs did you miss that wow you're
Green Jello man the one who just went to
give me a drink the state fair butter
princess that's the one my point is
school's definitely a virgin these shots
are so interesting
your powers
it's my best friend that you're talking
about
oh nice she is a virgin and that beats
sleeping with creeps like you
got it girl he's sour I think the lead
singer wants me only because he thinks
that you're a virgin I heard them
talking what I'm not even a back door
virgin anymore
wow I couldn't even go to Flags the next
day I had to stay home and sit on a bag
of frozen peas
they're both excellent I know I actually
think Megan Fox is really good in this
she's always been really good she got so
screwed by Hollywood and Amanda Seyfried
is like just so incredible did you see
the job out of course not Roxy you're a
loss I've seen Ted 2.
when I don't think he's really singing
[Music]
I kind of do he's very breathy do you
think he's salty yeah I mean I'm a big
OC girl
[Music]
[Applause]
that tattoo
oh she does have feelings for her huh oh
yeah they're obviously both into each
other
oh oh no don't pull away she's afraid
why did it turn her hand green
oh
she's got this like really subtle
sexiness Stillness to her Megan Fox for
the win
I don't see it
oh now it's a concert Devil's cattle
oh [__] oh no oh no is this really
happening right now
I know where to go the exit door
use your smart bombs
this way
wow Jennifer you didn't really seem to
react to all that violence yes she's in
love
Jennifer oh thank God you guys are all
right I've been looking everywhere for
you too
oh I wonder if he's a baddie I want us
to get to a familiar place okay this
one's in shock isn't that
he really pushed the drink
you think he was like vampire glaring
her
let's go the van I want to go to your
really cool van Nene
literally take her from the van
you should let your friend go in the van
awful
no yeah obviously obviously
skinny and twisted and evil like this
petrified tree I saw when I was a kid oh
my God you never let your friend get in
the van
yes just like that tree
yeah the way a shot does have this like
late 80s early 90s Vibe about it it's
kind of like a Cruel Intentions Flair
totally this is crazy Jennifer
they took her in their spooky fan with
the windows all blacked out did you get
the making model
cheese and Fries there's a very specific
Style
there's like a rock Gothic Flair so
strange
maybe I'm going crazy
scream energy let's go
yeah
so much has happened in the last 20
minutes
that Jello that's my new nickname for
you
for yellow
I would at least grab a weapon Like a
Knife yeah anything baseball bat these
all qualify as weapons
grab some jello
where are your parents
[Music]
boom whoa
she got turned yo
this is just another night with her on
MGK man
what happened saying he didn't cheat but
I feel like I don't know Chad
thank you
was she looking for beer jello
oh she needs meat my mom got that at
Boston Market
um
Boston Market slabs
bones babe
[Applause]
oh
Wicked
she cold
oh
scared
I'd be a little scared too yeah good
[Music]
foreign
's been thrashing her around
[Music]
I wonder what the vampire rules are in
this movie is that what you're thinking
is happening I thought this was a
vampire but that's all I ever heard
about it oh
okay then I'm with you I also knew this
was a vampire movie Incredible
I hope you called the cops oh
I'm Jennifer
[Music]
really relatable don't tell my mom about
this I never tell on you
they're besties BFF the necklace where's
it at Monistat
you were to have a tendency to overreact
you remember when we were in Girl Scout
camp and you totally thought that there
was an earthquake but it was just two
guys with a ghetto blaster a what she's
gaslighting people died Jennifer anybody
that we know
we know everyone
sucks to be them I guess
Savage
what is wrong with you what's wrong with
you
besides the obvious surface flaws
wow I knew it was real
I'd been up all night scrubbing the
Carnage off the linoleum why to hide for
her friend if that's not effective this
is a dark
dark day for a Devil's Kettle JK Simmons
interesting we lost eight precious
students including Ahmed from India
several parents she wanted to suck as
well
laughs
now more than ever
but aside your teenage concerns about
who's a cool dude
or who's a hoe
who's a cool dude who's a hoe are you a
teacher
what's the choice there was it because
of the fire no I think it's used to
always added some weird questions she
barfed up this like disgusting prickly
stuff that looked like a roadkill and
like so many needles mixed together
she probably just inhaled a whole bunch
of smoke or something
yeah
this guy it was like evil ship has no
smart balloons that's why he's so dumb
not saying that to be a dill hole ship I
don't tell Whoppers and I'm not crazy I
didn't say you were crazy what are these
kids saying
I don't tell Whoppers hey Nene
oh hi Colin whoa who's this guy who
looks familiar well I'm glad you didn't
die
thanks
seriously not even a dressing chip how
are you friends with Colin Gray I just
damn we've created non-fiction together
he's a really good writer he's like all
dark and emotional
emotions love him have a secret I'm like
that too I'm American related no chip
honey not all obvious about it like a
poser yep you're boring yep know
yourself
who's this guy
we saw him once before for a second
hi
what the hell Craig said that he always
thought you and me would make a totally
banging couple
so that's
so weird
which one was Craig I think it was Chris
Pratt oh yeah what up Craig I feel my
heart Jonas I think it's broken mine too
oh this will help him grief it's what
Craig would have wanted
yeah ah Craig's a good guy oh she's
gonna kill him
I believe that's where this is headed
look at this lucky actor yeah totally
he'll have this for the rest of his life
I know he just watches it every day why
are you so warm
studies
shutties
that means shut up if you didn't know oh
okay shutties
I can't do it with these animals
watching us what
oh look mosquito the blood from the
mosquito
oh my God it's like Snow White
they're waiting
for
movie rated PG
oh
might be a hard PG-13
oh God
grief is a [__]
let it all out kids
if you heard that and you were a teacher
would you go running probably I have a
hook for a hand too
just hope we
hope we are courage
here in our upcoming album oh so he's
still alive huh yeah why wouldn't he be
he's the perp
I don't know whether I mean wow
you dream about
dream some bad people were trying to
nail you to a tree
with hammers and
Big Steaks and [__] okay
this movie is awesome
come on come on I know come on just show
a little bit would you
just love that she went randomly
swimming in the lake
I feel so scrumptious
for you you should be happy for me
because I am having the best day since
like Jesus invented the calendar Jesus
didn't invent the calendar yes he did
you take that back they're lying hold on
so blow it off it'll just be a minute
who's the needy one now hey I need to
see you right now barely hear you knock
it off Camille
what that's like the famous gift is it
yeah I've never seen that you've never
seen people do a Halloween costume and
they always have the lighter no that is
really dangerous and stupid for people
to do that I gotta go
I am a god
okay fiery death trip last night and now
a cannibal psycho takes down the biggest
guy in school come on it's [__]
it's not freaked freaked hearted
[Laughter]
you're shaking oh I'm cold it's very
cold out here keep them warm you want my
hoodie oh
chip is useless our Town's only bar had
burned to the ground and our star
linebacker was someone's Snack Pack
this whole country got a huge tragedy
boner for Devil's Kettle
oh
[Music]
the flowers showing the passing of time
what are these random people they focus
on I know like chip we figured things
could only get better
we had Faith jokes on you life is tough
we were [__] idiots yep through the
trees has become our unofficial Anthem
they have decided to release it as a
benefit single oh no what's going on
they used us you take that back
needyless Nikki girls we need them now
more than ever that's enough clever what
a way to become famous I'm already sick
of that song yeah it's really poorly
pretty do you think they put fake
pimples on Megan Fox's face yeah there's
no way the real Megan Fox grows pimples
impossible my skin is breaking out and
my hair is dull and lifeless
still looks so hot it's like I'm one of
the normal girls nope never possible to
look normal are you PMSing or something
PMS isn't real needy it was invented by
the boy run media to make us seem crazy
take notes take notes I actually wanted
to uh to ask you something you want to
know if I'll go out with you no I don't
how did you just go ahead with the pitch
[Laughter]
okay
um
oh I feel bad there's a midnight showing
of Rocky Horror at The Bijou next
weekend
like boxing movies
he's into maggot rock he wears nail
polish my bigger than that well I think
he's really cool
you do come by my place I just got
aquamarine on DVD it's about this girl
who's like half sushi
I guess she has sex to a blue hole or
something
kill him because because needy thinks
he's cool or and trap him for needy oh
well she loves needy she wants needy
hmm
hi chip kill chip so I'm talking to your
mysterious pal Colin Gray again no he
was asking Jennifer out on a date that's
weird it is weird sure I'd like that I
went to Super Target and picked up more
condoms so thanks nice dude have they
had sex I don't think so I think he just
keeps buying condoms and he keeps having
to throw them out but is she a backdoor
virgin
uh
we can Google it really if you want it's
Jim and Jasmine
my mom has holiday sense too
this is nice
she really likes him I know and he's so
I can't wait for him to die
he's like Ashton Kutcher hey don't don't
diminish Ashton Kutcher I do love Ashton
Kutcher
[Music]
oh he's gonna die right now I know it's
gonna be beautiful
where is she bringing him to
why is he seem so concerned because
because the lighting in the neighborhood
changed
okay I think bring your bandana just in
case bud
it does look a little suspicious it's
really dark here make her come outside
that's Megan Fox be worth the risk yeah
full for sure yeah it doesn't matter I
don't care bring me to a graveyard yeah
take me to a morgue I don't care
Oh weird
actually I think I'd turn around now
really you wouldn't see this all the way
through I don't I think I would call
text hey your house seems boarded up
wouldn't do that
oh she's adapted she's going like full
Dexter slippery swirl yeah it's um it's
supposed to make it feel good for the
girl oh let's go chip but what about
yourself chip
right
you got the wrong mindset my friend I
think chip will be just fine
oh it's like a seance what's going on
here ritual
he thinks it's a romantic Ash gesture
you can play mommy and daddy
so far so good honestly yeah might as
well
do you even know my last
why are you doing this you give me such
a wetty
already
what does that mean I think what I don't
know
who's to say though
look at the parallels yeah actually
there's chips growing on me I know he's
growing on someone right now you know
what I mean no what do you mean um I
can't explain
are you scared I mean I thought boys
like you were really into Vermin and
death and [__] nice Hardware Ace
that was a good one
like a snake
oh puncture wound God that's so emo
I need you frightened
I literally hate watching this
oh is she like connected
oh yeah what the hell I think she's
connected in some way to Jennifer
because of what I don't know
[Music]
gnarly I feel bad for the people who had
to light those candles continuity on
them it's tough
uh chip you're misreading this whole
situation chip thinking he's giving a
woman
thought he was rocking the hell out of
this situation am I too big
yes champ that's the problem is this
something I did
that was a sick shot that's a good
effect damn nice
so this is the only real vampire aspect
of her is that she sucks blood I think
well she needs blood to live here but
she doesn't turn anybody into vampires
she can be in the daytime different set
of vampire rules
wow if you're chip right now you're
feeling like butthole it's an
interesting movie because it's like not
just a vampire film it's a high school
adolescent film totally 100 of my vibe
no pull it together
I'm up in the car
oh
I don't know
I'm getting scared wow what an entrance
you were right
[Applause]
you're a terrible friend Jennifer
I'm kind of feeling like needy's a
little bit bad friend too
why she's gotta help her bring in an
emergency room that won't do anything
all right I'm just gonna go to bed hi
median up with the screaming you're such
a cliche
I'm not gonna bite you
is that my Evil Dead t-shirt that's your
question
yeah
yeah she loves you
good for them but I feel like a needy
really loves
the other girl
the other girl really
just using her
the other girl's name Jennifer I guess
you forgot the name of the movie
Megan's body
yeah needy loves Jennifer man they
really had him go at it huh
thing oh my God all right okay so you
remember the night of the fire I got
really messed up
and those guys from Low Shoulder
totally evil
agents of Satan with a really awesome
haircuts all right let's see what
happened here are you even sure she's a
[__] virgin man
oh they have to be virgins to turn them
so they drove me out to the falls and I
kept looking for a way to escape but
it's really
dark out there also do you think she's
been going after virgins oh good
question we had a waxing moon tonight
you guys just like the ritual set how
interesting so you're like witchcraft
but they're not vampires right but get
it nice and tight though because I don't
want to get [__] clawed oh do they
throw into that hole oh I forgot about
the hole with the ping pong balls you
want to be a big loser or do you want to
be rich and awesome like that guy from
Maroon 5. everyone wants to be like Adam
everyone wants to be maroon 5. we come
here tonight to sacrifice the body of
what's your name again Tiffany
my name is Jennifer super don't tell
them
damn nursing Megan Fox act this much
she's good we're going to have to
butcher you and bleach you and then door
care is going to wear your face but
because she's not a virgin she can't be
sacrificed
[Applause]
[Music]
don't knock your head to this
okay
I'm clapping cause I know she's gonna
come back with a vengeance it should
have killed me but for some reason
didn't
sex saved her life
you hear that kids I woke up and
I found my way back to you
but then you tried to scare her and then
you connected yourself to her how why I
couldn't bring myself to hurt you
I mean I'm a really good friend
you said she was a bad friend are you
gonna pay for that windshield huh good
friend would
I meant
you made it up oh no way does your host
family know you're alive
does anyone know you're alive Jennifer
hi when I'm full I'm like
unkillable like I can do [__] like this
watch
oh it's really cool just watch look why
when she was eating her own hair I hated
that
some X-Men [__] right what do you mean
when you're full you don't need maybe
you should talk to somebody about these
disturbing thoughts
ah what a manipulator we're all really
concerned especially chip I think he may
be having second thoughts about you
leave why would you tell her that much
for not admit to eating people I feel
like needy should have read between the
lines there oh yeah definitely what are
you doing
um you said to leave
see you at school
I feel you girl somebody doesn't want
you there you got to get out she's a
little gaslighter that Jennifer though
huh I'm like team Jennifer
something about you in real life you
don't want to be nicknamed needy under
any circumstances
the sacrifice isn't pure
she should convince everybody in town to
have sex so they're all not at risk that
would be a finale would you lose your
virginity if you heard that you couldn't
die as long as you had sex
yeah school-wide announcement your only
safety find him
what's going on you're breaking up with
me is this about Jennifer yes but I
promise you this is the last thing I
care about you I don't think Jed needs
to attack virgins though or do you think
she can take out anybody yeah yeah I
think so Jennifer's evil
I know
I've been through the occult section at
the library five times
my library has an occult section they're
called Devil's Kettle High School I
would have assume it would but the human
sacrifice is impure the result may still
be attained but the demon demon ever
reside in the soul of the victim she
must forever feed on flesh to sustain
the demon
um
so they don't have to be virgins oh yes
the dance
be like an all-you-can-eat buffet
she's having chips on the menu oh nicely
done it's not that I don't believe you I
just don't believe this God this is a
nightmare
I mean you sound crazy I wouldn't
believe you either I ordered your
corsage it's an orchid it was like
twelve dollars it's pretty good for an
orchid chip it's not safe for us to be
together right now
oh this food is making me feel bad for
chip what happened to chip
ladies pepper spray I can take care of
myself I've been using the Bowflex
if your parent you don't let your kid
out right
don't eat it don't eat it don't eat it I
really have a thing against that
oh she like fully transforming she has
to feed and if she doesn't feed she's in
trouble she just fed now that was like
yesterday bro her hair's falling out she
needs blood how often does she need to
feed how often do you need to eat
every three to four hours stop judging
Jennifer she didn't she didn't ask for
this
I like that I made up a whole storyline
that she could only kill virgins I kind
of just believed you until the movie
clarified they're just like yeah yeah
it's like oh that's crazy yeah it's made
up people at home probably like nope
wow if he used his other hand he could
have cut his throat open I was thinking
that too welcome to the Supreme forma
[Applause]
chip which path did you take to go
I'm confused moms like take pepper spray
but I won't drive you there
can you hear me calling your name you
know how needy has been really upset
since Colin Gray died wild outfit choice
I don't want to say this [__]
needy and Colin were intimate
this is how she's gonna get him to hook
up I mean they were porking on a
semi-regular basis oh that is so messed
up she and Colin were doing things that
you have never even heard of okay total
Varsity moves like what what back doors
I want to hear the library I care about
you so much
more than I've ever had the guts too it
is oh dude don't fall for it if you're
him what are you doing
I mean he's single now right
no chip no chip
[Music]
he looks like I'm Adam Levine wannabe
yeah that might be very intentional Sam
better than me what why you're gonna be
so mad at me right now but boys are so
stupid
well I'd be mad of course they are
taking a word for it clearly and like
maybe just told him yeah no it's totally
obvious oh she feels it how are they
connected like that I don't understand
this
[Music]
please
man when are they gonna get their
comeuppance they Gotta Die
[Music]
put two and two together man one chip
show me a breaststroke
get there babe
she just takes off the whole dress
do you want to see chip die or no
ah kind of not as strong as before
now you can't
I'm sorry
this just feels weird
oh [__]
well what are you gonna do just yell
some dialogue at her I think
and if he did kiss you again were you
gonna keep him alive
one flower
corsage don't stop keep going there's no
rest period here but it's an orchid
that's 12 worth of orchid right there
gymnast oh nope yes yes she is
oh there he is
[Applause]
ah oh he's gonna bleed out
I try to get out of the water guys
try to warn you chip definitely infected
now oh
what would she becoming pepper spray
[Applause]
[Music]
oh no
whoa she got a whole new set of powers
here fly
covering yeah it kind of looks dope it's
not that impressive but do you have
you were such a player hater
[Laughter]
anybody that you want Jennifer
so
you want or is it because you're just
really insecure
I was the snowflake Queen two years ago
when you were socially relevant and you
didn't need laxatives to stay skinny wow
get her I am going
to eat your soul
and [__]
I thought you only murdered boys I go
both ways
whoa chip oh
it didn't seem to do much
tampon
yeah you seem like you might be blogging
I'm so happy too
oh
oh chip gonna die I don't think so no
he's definitely dead oh definitely said
yeah
you have a flip phone use it it's
probably all wet and broken what about
hers
stop working
no no no you're not going anywhere no
second you're fine honey you're fine I
think I already died before you got here
but I woke up when I heard your voice oh
that's actually really sweet chip I love
you I love you too he's gonna be okay
literally delirious
[Music]
put Band-Aid on it
it's fine
[Laughter]
post credit scene he's good how are we
gonna kill Adam Brody I don't think the
movie's gonna do it
Circle people's picture total hottie
I wish
and of course yeah
don't eat your hair she should have gone
back to the dance to feed she didn't
need any more you don't understand how
hunger works
I think I do
[Music]
[Laughter]
what is happening you killed my [__]
boyfriend you got that monster she swore
yo this is Laura
it's for cutting boxes
yes I thought it was the more clever
whoa
[Music]
What's Happening Here
oh I wonder if that's what kept them
connected this bait must be
[Music]
but that's so weird that that would have
whatever I'll accept it
[Music]
grunge
oh no
she's gonna be looked at as just a
murderer now
blood pooling in the neck really good
where's Jennifer's mom
oh
ask it you shall receive oh my God
oh my God
oh that sucks and she has to suffer
through all this now
that does suck
and now needy's gonna be blamed for
eating the bodies and stuff oh she's in
there she's in the Asylum I'm a
different person now a person who uses
curse words and kicks orderlies and sees
things that aren't there
this might get lucky for once in your
miserable life
wow there clearly should have been a
Jennifer's Body too with her let's go
needy's body
oh cool
needy's body go kill Adam Brody
is this the only Power she got oh there
it is okay
[Music]
yeah like all kinds of powers but I
guess she doesn't need to feed
[Music]
ah so I guess that's stuff that they do
dump does go somewhere do you think she
killed the mom no so why'd she ditch the
murder of it uh but that's a different
murder weapon oh that's not the box
cutter you right yeah that's why they
had that line viewers like yourself
that was a bad moment for me for sure
East towards Madison
up in lunch area I know this guy
following this rock band must be one
hell of a group that's Hendricks
tonight's going to be their last show
oh she's gonna kill the band all right
cool
yeah shoulder
we should see that there should be
another movie this is awesome so
oh my God there's more
[Music]
okay maroon 5. this is their last show
here it is they kept filming that's good
[Music]
this was a different time in the early
2000s where they were not afraid to show
what the entire sequel was in a post
credit I feel like there's a longer
version of this movie out there
all right
wow I'm really into the soundtrack what
did you think Roxy stronger that was
awesome I mean like I we've heard great
things about it but I didn't know if it
had just been over hyped and not all of
the powers are like full extended things
make complete sense but it's so good and
fun that I don't really care yeah that's
probably the best way to put it because
it didn't bother me that all of a sudden
you can float I don't care that's great
let me see it yeah I had no idea what to
expect going in all I heard was that it
was a a fun movie and that Megan Fox is
actually really good in it that's all I
ever heard was Megan Fox's actually they
also has a vampire movie and I feel like
that term is used so loosely yeah what
would you say after watching it is this
a vampire film or no it's probably the
most efficient way to describe it's the
same way people call Last of Us a zombie
show where you're like yeah I mean it's
kind of a zombie thing but that's not a
zombie show though I know but it's like
the easiest way to explain it but do you
want me to explain to you why it's not
please don't
I I understand why people would say it's
a it's a vampire thing completely
because it's like okay yeah she feeds
off people but that sets you up for a
whole different kind of movie I think
when someone says that you think you're
gonna go into
uh you think there'd be a little bit
more rules associated with it and
whatnot but totally and then I wrote the
entire movie oh yeah I appreciate that
that did not at all affect my viewing
experience I did not a one minute go oh
yeah she's right they're targeting all
these like jock virgins in here uh that
was not the film at all I do feel like
there's a longer version out there you
know what I'm very curious I'm gonna
just quickly Google right now you were
saying that a longer version currently
exists or there's a longer cut to have
been made left on The Cutting Room floor
I feel like there's probably I mean I
feel yeah the latter okay um I feel like
there definitely could be a sequel that
would be awesome to this not that
everything needs an effing sequel this
movie is just great as it is everybody
extended version it is an extended
version yeah I had a feeling there were
parts of the way the movie was edited
and knowing this director's other work
like I bet this movie actually breathed
a little bit better and took its time
and more scenes why don't we watch that
version oh because I didn't know it
about it until five seconds ago again
I just had
I actually thought that this was so
tight though like the the cut the edit
was really really tight solid there's
none of the things that were kind of
strange and it's bothered me it was just
like oh okay I'm gonna fill in the
blanks here and sometimes I filled in
the blanks wrong yeah we're really good
at helping the movie out throwing a good
alley oop to the film
I feel like my adjustment it was an
interesting choice I think it could have
helped help to flesh it out uh the world
a little bit more I think this is one of
those movies I think two would also be
cooler on a re-watch because there was a
lot more thematically going on on its
mind than I was ex I I thought it would
be a little bit more just of a
straightforward like pulpy
sexual Thriller kind of film and it
wasn't I was like okay there's a lot of
commentary about adolescent angst and
this also uh what people will do to sell
out for fame and and striving for that
and even Jennifer was because I didn't
even get it that sense until the very
end with her and needy when needy was
saying how she used to be popular
and actually takes laxatives now to stay
skinny all these things I didn't pick up
on any of that from Jennifer throughout
the movie that that was something she
sort of craved did you no I agree with
that I do think that like if we're
really dissecting this Jennifer's
character seemed super popular at the
beginning super popular in the middle
and super Popular by the end she's
always being asked out by the hottest
people anybody she talks to will go
anywhere with her she can convince
anybody of anything in class everybody
kind of like knows that she's the [__]
popular girl so then when when needy all
of a sudden is like two years ago when
you were relevant right I thought you
would relevant this whole time
definitely definitely again like didn't
really bother me but if they wanted to
Pepper that in a little more if that was
supposed to be the big reveal like she
used to be cool now she's not that's why
she's doing all this I really feel like
it was because she was in love with
needy and she and she was really the
needy one oh yes well done yes yes see
some of my points are sound very
impressive very impressive let's see if
you can maintain the rest of our
conversation now
okay uh
fine let me throw it back at you before
I think about something brilliant at the
end of the day who did you like better
Jennifer and Edie
I mean Jennifer is the more captivating
performer to watch I think I think needy
is a more fleshed out character the one
with more Dimensions I would say though
that like I get why people talked about
but she's kind of utilized like that way
in in the film itself they want her to
be a bit mysterious and for her when
she's on screen to really count like
needy's The Kill the character with the
character Arc she's the one who really
develops she's the one with more
exploration and I do think this movie
was a little had a little too much on it
that's why I'm actually very I feel like
we should just watch the Extended Cut I
wish I was aware of that before filming
why didn't I do that because I didn't
know about it until after we were done
filming the reaction to the theatrical
cut that's so strange
so
should we start again no no no no let's
keep this train rolling
um she put the movie on the extenders
I'm okay right now we got this maybe we
could just find the extended cut scenes
and I'll just implement it into the
reaction
so yeah I do think that because with all
they had on their mind there were there
were times where it was kind of
zigzagging for me where I'm like I'm not
sure what to really focus on but what I
thought that this movie had going so
well for it was they had this that
angsty grungy like Gothic dark tone
throughout and because of its strange
ethereal teenager Vibe its tone was
always keeping me interested even when I
was like okay this is kind of a bit of a
zigzagging experience because I was like
all right is this really going to be
about Jennifer anedi's friendship is
that what this is really about is this
going to be about them evolving as
teenagers uh you know it's like what are
the parallels between adolescence and
this morphing of mutation she's going
through there were there were so many
things that I thought they wanted to
comment on and uh was it always the
smoothest no but was it always
entertaining yes and I think at the end
of the day with a movie like this that's
what counts the most is like it was a
very very entertaining film like I was
never bored one second totally the whole
time I was like what do you think's
Happening Here what do you think's going
on next um and I was very entertained
too also I think that I am more willing
to be lenient with movies like this
because give me a teenage girl movie and
I watch it 10 out of 10 times like I
love coming age films I love things that
take place in high school I love the
juxtaposition between Jennifer and needy
and like how they are navigating their
way through school and and one of them
being much more just like classic mean
girl and the other one being the nerdier
one both of them being super hot though
and actually neither of them being nerdy
in any way shape or form I love that
like I'm a big CW free-form head so not
that this is like that because obviously
this is a more intense I know or people
hate the word elevated now but elevated
version of that which I appreciated
the I think if they were going to try to
spice it up a little bit we could have
improved some of our B and C characters
like we got both of their moms for a
second at one random Point yeah um but
nothing no idea about really either of
them and then we got the brother of
crispy guy it was named Chris chip Chips
uh sister who made an appearance and it
was like take pictures with your sister
and it's like what happened there uh
then I guess his mom was in it for a
second even chip just a general call and
we didn't get to know that much the dude
that was The Jock that had the best day
of his life with Megan Fox before he got
eaten alive as lasagna like all these
kind of characters where it's just like
okay that's there's not that much there
you know I'm not rooting for any of them
at all so it doesn't really matter what
happens to them I think what they could
have done going off what you're saying
is make the town because there was so
much emphasis on what the band did and
then the town coming in I mean what the
band did and how I was trying to
Spotlight on the town blah blah and I
think if they made this small town Vibe
feel more alive and see how they're
really being affected by it because like
when when they when they're talking with
not crispy man now you got the second
one
uh when Chip's mom is like here's the
pepper spray have you seen about the the
kids being murdered I was like I wasn't
even really aware that the town was
aware about the murders of these of
these boys that was happening and I
think if we witnessed some of how the
town was being affected and changing by
these circumstances and events that just
would have helped it feel a little bit
more lived in
um you know where I'm thinking that
might be where
where what the extent of God yeah
probably yes
no you are not incorrect at all I do
think that if they're if there's
something in there probably is that like
the reveal that this man is lasagna in
the forest we see his parents kind of
see it but we don't see yes the news
going around uh we have that one radio
station that was kind of interesting too
that you got 80s Vibes at the beginning
I got 90s Vibes then we start seeing the
flip phone we hear the cars from 2003.
yeah you know like okay this is actually
2000s movie but it did really have
nostalgic 90s Vibes to me well yeah it's
kind of like those movies
um I I forget the arrows in them are
movies like I've seen movies like
Heather's have you seen Heather's 80s
Heathers and then I thought of I haven't
actually seen Cruel Intentions but
everything I've seen A Cruel Intentions
I was kind of getting the Vibes of
that's one of my favorite five movies of
all time really that's top five I think
so yeah what are the other five four
Goodwill Hunting Princess Bride Role
Models cool intentions
uh Wizard of Oz like you had to squeeze
cruelty screens in there no no you were
like it's definitely I say cruel
attention so I'm gonna mention yeah top
10 if you've heard for years I've been
telling I love that movie I love love
love that movie it is so good it did
have kind of Cruel Intentions Vibes
except that's not a horror movie
although the stuff that's happening is
after
yeah
but sort of that like surreal offbeat
path in the high school that I thought
this movie was uh at least aiming to do
I was appreciating because there were
some interesting directing choices I
thought did you think it was scary
not really no no was it like would you
would you call this a horror movie
that's that was the fun part about
trying to see what I'd like genre
categorize it as because it's I'm like I
guess it's a horror movie Thriller more
it's like a supernatural High School
movie it's kind of Thriller because like
they have moments where they were going
for horror but it never felt
truly like a full-blown horror movie I
am very curious what that Extended Cut
is like now what do you think maybe this
is answered the next time to cut but
what do you think the deal with swirly
is what's swirly the water that was
going oh the actual sword yeah yeah this
really thing and then we see where it
comes out but like that kind of has
nothing to do with the plot of the movie
at all
right yeah I felt like Jennifer would be
dumping bodies yeah me too like at some
point we were gonna see like I guess the
knife pops out there but the fact that
the scientists have been searching high
and low and can't figure out where it is
but it's just going out to this tree oh
my God there's a clear spot right here
did you see all the balls and stuff like
what is the D what was the deal with
that is that where the supernatural
Powers come from or maybe it's some type
of commentary about you know like when
we descend to the depths of Hell
everything eventually Rises to the
surface Roxy
[Laughter]
again it didn't really bother me because
it didn't distract me from anything else
but it's just like that was an
interesting choice that we spent time on
this swirly thing that really had
nothing to do with yeah we didn't put
the bodies there we didn't say that
that's where the powers came from even
though maybe you could jump to think
that
yeah you know what I gotta I gotta find
out Jennifer's Body
what's something like you Google
Extended Cut differences we could do
that we just go unanswered questions oh
okay
facts and expert answers
is there a deeper meaning to Jennifer's
Body
feminist film Theory explained that in
the male subconscious female power is
inversely proportional to male power
therefore they cannot coexist because of
the fear of emasculation
the more power woman gains the more she
is dehumanized and then punished
interesting I agree if you concur yes
uh agree yeah I don't think female power
it always makes me feel less than so I
prefer women do not have power you wrote
it yourself I did submit an article to
uh
feministtheoryish.com that's what I was
thinking
what's Jennifer attracted to needy yes
written by a feminist Diablo Cody
uh interesting it doesn't really answer
the question what else did Diablo Cody
write uh oh yeah it's a good question
let's see also love the line written by
a feminist written by Bruno
self-proclaimed feminist this can't be
anti-feminism because it's written by
somebody who claims they're a feminist
I guess it's fem is it a 2009 film
I don't really look at it as like
feminist or not feminist I just like the
movie yeah I didn't really see it as
like anything that was oh he did Dolly I
love [__] Dolly I haven't seen tally
oh it's a good one we would go up go up
like down no up I want to say the most
Telly Jennifer's Body Juno
young adult oh okay oh yeah so they do
write a lot of these like coming of age
stories
okay
I mean overall it was a fun film with a
lot of exciting visual motifs good
soundtrack
I was so into the soundtrack that was
one of the best parts for me I could
tell you're really digging on that side
you know what I also really loved the
costumes it was very very early 2000s
yes like the juicy the jean skirt the um
just the like stripes on the tops
yeah the polos for the guys all that too
very much was aware what was your
favorite outfit you know
when she was wearing the Evil Dead shirt
the part of the video where you try to
burn your tongue or
I think you two would get mad at us for
trying to do that to be like you're
encouraging kids to try dangerous things
it was crazy how her tongue like
I can disintegrate it was a good effect
yeah it was cool I've never seen that is
it gif GIF yeah how do you say GIF gif
it's graphic so GIF but I think they
said that it's Jiff really messing with
us yeah yeah and a lot of good slang in
here too okay what's your favorite salty
good never heard that before I loved
Jello man I'm not letting Jello go I've
never heard that ever applied in any
context in my life Green Jello did
people do kids talk like that did you
talk like that in high school I do feel
like this movie made up a ton of
terminology that at the time if it had
if I had seen it when it came out I
would have used okay for sure yeah one
of those because what did this year did
this drop in 2003 2009 2009 yeah okay we
have IMDb right in front of us yeah
yep see it now
even as you said that I was like we're
not even on this movie
it's literally right there in 2009 so I
was graduating high school that year
okay so I for sure
what
yeah it's all been alive yeah 2001.
because I graduated high school yeah I'm
a vampire
I stay so young because all the blood
that I suck
but I definitely like if I if this has
come out and they've been saying things
like salty and I saw a guy that I
thought was cute I'd been like he's
salty definitely it's just so insulted
I'm like that just sounds uh off-putting
me totally now we use now Salty's uses
like they're bitter like something yeah
but Jello that's a really good one oh my
God you're Green Jello you could never
wait what is jello used in the as
jealous
yes you're so jello
you're so jealous you're actually the
Green Jello that's how feminist ride
movies apparently
yeah I do wonder how he came up with
some of this terminology was he just
like isn't Diablo a woman oh really oh
that makes more sense then oh wait no
I'm not sure
Johnny who later became her uh
yeah yeah okay I think so it says writer
producer actress okay we don't know the
uh
gender identification it's interesting
that her name or their name is devil
oh really is that what Diablo stands for
isn't that you know what I need to stop
like believing you on things because I'm
always like how fascinating yeah well
name meaning
Spanish for definitely you nailed it oh
yeah Diablo
that's cool oh clever
yeah I mean I like supernatural horror
stuff I guess I would still categorize
it as that for sure it was doing a lot
but I thought Megan Fox was excellent
she was so like she was seductive but
beyond that she had some great scenes
where this is most the most I've ever
really believed her like fully believed
her in every scene she was in well what
else are you comparing it to
transforming you know Transformers yeah
yeah I saw this one movie she did with
Simon Pegg ages ago where she was
finding it what about Amanda Seyfried I
don't know her work too well other than
like Mean Girls and Ted too I like I I
always assumed Amanda seyfried's a great
actress she's so so good I thought they
were both very believable and I thought
they had great chem some of my favorite
scenes were just them together and I
wish the movie kind of did more of that
was was just them hanging out because I
thought they had really great chemistry
they did I I think it's really difficult
for to do what Megan Fox did here which
was like be believably an utter [__]
yeah like it's actually the way that she
did it um but you still kind of love her
character she really nailed it I felt
like they both had the right pitch of
tone for what the director wanted to go
for with this film definitely because
you need a certain type of surrealistic
height and tone but you can't overdo it
or also becomes on like not believable
and I think with two very different
performances they both found that right
middle ground in order to make it still
believable in a heightened reality she
was the the Regina George of this movie
yes in a lot of ways yeah you have semen
girls yeah I love Mean Girls It's really
good yeah is it one of your top five
favorite movies no cruel intense yeah
but Mean Girls is out there Legally
Blonde is up there you seen that one
yeah yeah okay just checking
okay
have you seen The Matrix Revolutions
no I only saw the first Matrix I only
saw it this year I know this year 2023
that they said 22 yeah
in the last year
I mean very technical here yeah I feel
like wow when did you turn on me what
happened sorry all right no usually I
try to help you out how are we going to
expect them to love me when I can't even
get you no I got you I got you covered
oh twist the knife well uh we'll drain
it out of ten then we'll call it a night
I just died and you didn't
I know
I did a bit of being hi caring I was
done maybe a eight and a half I really
like that that's really high
you're so bad as hard what's yours
7.5 okay really good
yeah that's solid yes seven to seven
point five
it's going down a little bit
do you think it's a four and a half it's
gone it fluctuates no I thought that was
awesome I enjoyed the hell out of that
movie have you seen the invitation
remember she did no oh that is one of my
favorite horror movies really yeah so
this isn't as good that's a what I
appreciate is it's like the invitation
is if you want to talk about elevated
horror that is is it is so like such a
slow build it is entirely like so slow
and you you're the whole time you're
like I don't know what's going where
this movie's going but I am
uncomfortable and I don't even know why
who's in it
um have you seen upgrade
the the tech one with uh dude Tom not
Tom Hardy but it looks like Tom Hart
Logan Marshall agrees okay then maybe I
think I saw it on an airplane
that's how you watched it I think so
people were talking about it for a while
and then I think I saw it there oh what
a terrible way to experience that I
actually don't know how much I
I think I saw it I don't remember movies
perfectly that's the truth about me I
remember everything about TV shows I I
movies I do not remember movies I do
have a hard time recalling especially if
I'm under a certain type of influence
tired yeah that's what it is I'm very
tired sometimes in life you're just hot
and tired it's tired you're a good mood
but tired you know how it goes guys
uh yeah that he's in it but it's really
it's a gray film and it's very much like
not this it's it's super slow is the guy
from upgrade an invitation or yeah yeah
yeah and he's uh I thought he was
phenomenal when I met him that was the
first thing I told him was like your
work performance in the invitation blew
my mind why'd you meet him I was at the
premiere of upgrade you're so fancy yeah
yeah you've like interviewed super
famous people though yeah interviewed
Bohemian Rhapsody people yeah I did do
that
in Vegas they flew me there on a private
jet it's crazy really private jet yeah
good for you with the cast and then I
was front row to see Queen and got to
hang out with uh Brian May
and Roger Taylor oh you've clearly
ridden that momentum all the way to this
channel
that's how I got here